I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Hi there. I'm excited about today's episode. Well, it's a big day for Dunder Mifflin. It's a fun one. I think Michael Scott should kick off this episode. Oh, okay. Hello, hello. Top of the morning to ya. Woohoo. Green M&Ms. Nature's Viagra. Two of my favorite joke areas combined. It's gonna be a good day. What are his two favorite joke areas? M&Ms, Viagra,
我是珍娜·费舍。我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来《办公室》终极重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有身临其境的两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们是《办公室》。大家好。嗨。我为今天的剧集感到兴奋。嗯，对邓德米夫林来说这是个大日子。这集很有趣。我认为迈克尔·斯科特应该为这一集开个好头。哦，好吧。你好，你好。早上好。呜呼。绿色的M&M巧克力豆。大自然的伟哥。我最喜欢的两个笑点结合在一起了。这将是美好的一天。他最喜欢的两个笑点是什么？M&M巧克力豆，伟哥，
and St. Patrick's Day. Like, what are... Yeah, I'm not sure. I guess Viagra and Candy? Viagra and Holidays? Viagra and... Definitely Viagra. Definitely Viagra. I'm not sure what the second one is. Well, why don't you kick us off, Jenna, with what episode this is? This is St. Patrick's Day, Season 6, Episode 19, written by Jonathan Hughes, who is one of our writer's assistants, and directed by Randall Einhorn. I noticed in the shooting draft, Jenna, this episode was titled St. Patrick's Day Semi-Colon Town Hall. Huh. Because Joe Bennett is gonna have a town hall meeting. Wow. I know. Little tidbit there for ya. Great trivia there, and just coming in hot with the trivia today. Oh my gosh. Are we becoming that SNL sketch? Do you remember? The delicious dish? It was like
还有圣帕特里克节。就像，什么是……是的，我不确定。我猜是伟哥和糖果？伟哥和节日？伟哥和……绝对是伟哥。绝对是伟哥。我不确定第二个是什么。好吧，詹娜，你为什么不给我们开个头，说说这是哪一集？这是圣帕特里克节，第六季第十九集，由乔纳森·休斯编剧，他是我们的编剧助理之一，由兰德尔·艾因霍恩执导。我注意到在拍摄剧本中，詹娜，这一集的标题是《圣帕特里克节 分号 市政厅》。哈。因为乔·贝内特要开一个市政厅会议。哇。我知道。给你的一点小花絮。那里的趣事很棒，而且今天带着满满的趣事闪亮登场。哦，天哪。我们是在变成那个周六夜现场的素描吗？你还记得吗？美味的节目？就像
the NPR with the Molly Shannon and Anagastire. Yes. Oh, good times. I love it. Coming in hot. You surprised me with that one. Are we them? Maybe. Should we hear them? Let's hear them. Oh, Sam, can you find us the clip of them? So, Terry, what's your favorite kind of fiber? I like quinoa. Whoa. I threw you, didn't I? You thought I was gonna say barley? That was a real game changer. More like grain changer. Oh my gosh. It's one of the all-time greats. It really is. Molly Shannon has a fantastic book out. Hello, Molly. It's so good. I've actually been listening to the audiobook. I've been listening to her read it. Oh, that's so fun. It's really good. It's very raw and emotional. I mean, she's
带着莫莉·香农和安娜·加斯泰尔的国家公共广播电台。是的。哦，美好的时光。我喜欢它。闪亮登场。你用这个让我大吃一惊。我们是他们吗？也许。我们应该听听他们吗？让我们听听。哦，萨姆，你能帮我们找到他们的剪辑吗？那么，特里，你最喜欢哪种纤维？我喜欢藜麦。哇。我把你难倒了，对吧？你以为我会说大麦吗？那真是一个改变游戏规则的事。更像改变谷物。哦，天哪。这是史上最伟大的节目之一。真的是这样。莫莉·香农有一本非常棒的书出版了。你好，莫莉。太棒了。我其实一直在听有声书。我一直在听她朗读。哦，太有趣了。真的很好。非常原始和感性。我的意思是，她是
shares really deeply about her life. But God, I just, I admire her so much. I love her. Yeah, get her book. Book plug, Molly. And may I point out you guys have the same microphone set up as them. We do. As the delicious dish gals? That's why you and those ladies sound just as good. Well, I came in hot and we had an unexpected tangent. Back to the episode. I'm going to give you a summary. Good times. It's St. Patrick's Day, which is a big deal in Scranton, and the gang can't wait to celebrate after work. Dwight explains the fact that Jim is struggling with his return from paternity leave. Michael tries a little too hard with Joe Bennett and becomes jealous when she takes a shine to Daryl instead. Meanwhile, Andy and Aaron
对自己的生活进行了非常深入的分享。但是天哪，我只是，我太崇拜她了。我爱她。是的，买她的书。给书打个广告，莫莉。我可以指出你们俩用的麦克风设置和他们的一样吗。我们是的。就像美味节目的姑娘们一样？这就是为什么你和那些女士们听起来一样好。好吧，我闪亮登场了，我们有了一个意想不到的题外话。回到这一集。我要给你一个总结。美好的时光。今天是圣帕特里克节，这在斯克兰顿是一件大事，大家迫不及待地想在下班后庆祝。德怀特解释了吉姆在结束陪产假回归后所面临的挣扎。迈克尔在乔·贝内特面前表现得有点太刻意了，当乔转而对达里尔表现出好感时，他嫉妒了。与此同时，安迪和亚伦
have their first date in spite of Aaron being sick and a creepy foster brother. That was the storyline I forgot about. Same. When I was rewatching it, I'm like, wait, who's this guy? What is going on? That guy was so funny. They're whole dynamic. We'll get to it. Fast fact number one is the mail that we got from Caitlyn D in Philadelphia, Pennsylvania. Fun fact, Scranton has a 30% Irish population ranking third highest for medium cities in the US. Have you ever been to Scranton's St. Patrick's Day Parade? Did you know it was one of the largest in the country? Well, I have not been to the parade, but I can confirm that according to penlive.com, Scranton ranks seventh out of the nine largest St. Patrick's Day parades. I believe it because
尽管亚伦生病还有一个令人毛骨悚然的寄养兄弟，但他们还是有了第一次约会。那是被我遗忘的剧情线。我也是。当我重播的时候，我想，等等，这家伙是谁？怎么回事？这家伙太搞笑了。他们整个人际动态。我们待会儿会说到。快讯一来自费城彭城凯特·D的来信。趣事，斯克兰顿有30%的爱尔兰人口，在美国中型城市中排名第三。你去过斯克兰顿的圣帕特里克节游行吗？你知道它是全国最大的游行之一吗？嗯，我没去过游行，但我可以证实，根据penlive.com的报道，在圣帕特里克节九大最大游行中，斯克兰顿排名第七。我相信，因为
if you meet anyone from Scranton, one of the first things they tell you is you got to see our parade. Well, the parade has its own website with a countdown. They are already counting down to next year's parade. And according to the official website, they're the second largest in the country. So maybe they want to call someone over at penlive.com. Uh-oh. Get on it. Stir in the pot, Jenna. Well, you know. Next year, their parade is going to be on March 11, 2023. The parade kicks off with a parade day mass at St. Peter's Cathedral at 10 a.m., followed by the Brian P. Kelly Two-Mile Foot Race. And then after the race, the parade starts at 11.45 and lasts just under three and a half hours. That's a long time. It's a long parade. I don't know. How long is the Macy's Thanksgiving
如果你遇到任何来自斯克兰顿的人，他们告诉你的第一件事就是你必须去看看我们的游行。嗯，游行有它自己的网站，上面有倒计时。他们已经在为明年的游行倒计时了。根据官方网站，他们是全国第二大的游行。所以也许他们想给penlive.com打电话。哦，噢。行动起来。煽风点火，詹娜。嗯，你知道的。明年，他们的游行将在2023年3月11日举行。游行以上午10点在圣彼得大教堂举行的游行日弥撒拉开帷幕，随后是布莱恩·P·凯利两英里长跑。比赛结束后，游行将于11点45分开始，持续不到三个半小时。时间真长。这是一场漫长的游行。我不确定。梅西感恩节的游行有多长？
day parade? I like that we just came to this at the same moment. Like, wait, how long is a parade? I thought a parade was about an hour. Same. Well, this is not this one. No. They also get approximately 12,000 people at the parade each year. Wow. Internet says Macy's parade is roughly three to four hours. So same. Oh, big parade. Big parade. Who knew? I guess I've only been to more smaller local parades. I mean, my neighborhood does a little one for Fourth of July. It's about 30 minutes. Lady, that's not a parade. Sure it is. That's a neighborhood event. It's a parade. You get your, I mean, you can get, you decorate your bicycle or, you know, the little red like wagon and you decorate and you walk and neighbors have candy and they throw candy. Yes, a neighborhood
我喜欢我们同时想到这一点。就像，等等，游行有多长？我以为游行大约持续一个小时。我也是。嗯，这次可不是。不。他们每年大约有12,000人参加游行。哇。互联网说梅西游行大约三到四个小时。所以一样。哦，盛大的游行。盛大的游行。谁知道呢？我猜我只去过较小的本地游行。我的意思是，我的社区为独立日举办了一个小游行。大约30分钟。女士，那不是游行。当然是。那是社区活动。那是游行。你可以，我的意思是，你可以，你可以装饰你的自行车，或者，你知道，小红车之类的，你装饰然后你走路，邻居们有糖果，他们扔糖果。是的，社区
event. You're talking about a neighborhood event. I know. I can't just organize like 20 people on my street and call it a parade. Sure you can. Have you been to New Orleans? Those are real parades. No, no, in New Orleans, you can just like walk out after getting married and everyone starts dancing and people follow along and all of a sudden you're going through the streets with like 200 people. I don't, I will debate you on this forever. My neighborhood does a little Fourth of July parade. You're saying it's an event. I don't like it. Well, listen, I don't know what to say because I mean, I just think like you're saying I'm surprised this parade is three and a half hours long because our parade on my street for Fourth of July with the bicycles is much shorter.
活动。你在说社区活动。我知道。我不能只组织我街上的20个人就把它叫做游行。当然可以。你去过新奥尔良吗？那些才是真正的游行。不，不，在新奥尔良，你可以在结婚后走出去，每个人都开始跳舞，人们跟着跳，突然间你就带着200人走在街上了。我不会，我要就这个和你争论到永远。我的社区举办一个小型的独立日游行。你说这是一场活动。我不喜欢。好吧，听着，我不知道该说什么，因为我的意思是，我只是觉得你是在说我很惊讶这个游行持续了三个半小时，因为我们在独立日那天在街上的自行车游行要短得多。
No, I'm not saying that. I'm saying that you can have smaller parades or bigger parades. There's room for every type of parade. All right, I'll agree to that. Okay, fine. Shall we go on to fast fact number two? I guess. What kind of interview are we bringing this morning? I don't know. I think we're really tired. I know. We're a loopy. I know. Well, fast fact number two is that Greg Daniels always wanted us to film an episode in Scranton during the St. Patrick's Day parade, but we could not get the network to approve a budget to bring the entire cast and crew to Scranton. I thought this was such a huge mistake by the network. I agree. It would have been so great. It would have been a love letter to the city of Scranton, this amazing city who rallied
不，我不是那个意思。我的意思是你可以有小型游行或大型游行。各种类型的游行都有空间。好吧，我同意这一点。好吧，好吧。我们要进入快讯二吗？我猜吧。我们今天早上带的是什么类型的采访？我不知道。我觉得我们真的很累。我知道。我们有点晕头转向。我知道。好吧，快讯二就是格雷格·丹尼尔斯一直希望我们在圣帕特里克节游行期间在斯克兰顿拍摄一集，但我们无法让电视网批准预算来带全体演员和剧组去斯克兰顿。我认为电视网犯了一个巨大的错误。我同意。那会太棒了。这将是给斯克兰顿市的一封情书，这座支持该剧的了不起的城市，我很遗憾我们从未去过。听着，这就是我们在片场一直在说的一切。我们一直在争论这必须在剧集播出期间发生。
behind the show, and I'm so bummed we never got to go. Listen, that's everything that we were saying on set. We were constantly arguing that this had to happen during the run of the show. Yeah. Because the show never shot a single thing in Scranton, the entire run of the show, and we thought that that was wrong. Guess what? We're going to do an episode of Mom's Detective in Scranton. Yeah. There. The show that we talk about that doesn't exist. We're going to do it in Scranton. Well, listen, Greg thought maybe for this episode, we could get a few people to Scranton for the parade. They wouldn't pay for everybody. So originally, this episode opened with a Michael Talking Head during which we were going to show footage of people at the parade. Yes, like a montage.
是的。因为该剧在播出的整个过程中，没有在斯克兰顿拍摄过任何东西，我们认为这是不对的。你猜怎么着？我们要去斯克兰顿拍一集《妈妈侦探》。是的。在那里。我们谈论的不存在的节目。我们要去斯克兰顿拍。好吧，听着，格雷格认为也许对于这一集，我们可以带几个人去斯克兰顿参加游行。他们不会为所有人付钱。所以最初，这一集是以迈克尔的独白开头的，在此期间我们将播放游行人群的镜头。是的，就像蒙太奇一样。
Yes. Here is how it went. The Talking Head was, it's St. Patrick's Day, which is a huge deal in Scranton. There was a big parade on Saturday, third biggest parade in the country, according to the organizers. But if you ask me, it's the biggest. And then during that Talking Head, we were going to see Phyllis and Bob Vance dressed as royalty waving atop a Vance refrigeration float. That would have been amazing. They would have built it too. It would have been a giant refrigerator going down the road. Well, Angela, Randy told us that they started prepping this episode and they reached out to Mary at the Chamber of Commerce in Scranton. Yes. And the Steamtown Mall was going to give us a float that we could turn into a Vance refrigeration float. Come on.
是的。情况是这样的。独白是，今天是圣帕特里克节，这在斯克兰顿是一件大事。周六有一场盛大的游行，据组织者称，这是全国第三大游行。但如果你问我，这是最大的。然后在那个独白中，我们会看到菲利斯和鲍勃·万斯打扮成皇室成员，在一辆万斯制冷公司的花车上挥手。那会太棒了。他们也会建造它。那将是一个巨大的冰箱行驶在路上。好吧，安吉拉，兰迪告诉我们，他们开始筹备这一集时，联系了斯克兰顿商会的玛丽。是的。斯克兰顿购物中心要给我们一辆花车，我们可以把它变成万斯制冷公司的花车。拜托。
Do you see how supportive they were? But wait, there's more. We were going to have Creed march with the veterans wearing a highly decorated officer's uniform and Stanley was just going to be sitting on the sidelines in a lawn chair. So we shot this episode in January, but there was a problem. The parade is in March. Listen to this. The city of Scranton offered to move the entire parade one week earlier so that we could scoot down there and get this footage and get it into the episode in time before it aired. Come on. There's more. The Scranton Hilton blocked off a floor of rooms. The Steamtown Mall offered to give us their security for the cast and crew on the parade day. Mary also found a local hair salon to do the actor's hair and makeup for
你看他们有多支持？但这还没完。我们要让克里德和老兵们一起游行，穿着高度装饰的军官制服，而斯坦利只是坐在草坪椅上旁观。所以我们在1月拍摄了这一集，但出了个问题。游行在3月。听这个。斯克兰顿市主动提出将整个游行提前一周，以便我们可以赶到那里获取这些镜头，并在播出前及时将其剪入剧集中。拜托。还有呢。斯克兰顿希尔顿酒店封锁了一层客房。斯克兰顿购物中心主动提出在游行当天为演员和剧组提供安保。玛丽还找了一家当地的美发沙龙，免费为演员做发型和妆容。
free. Oh my gosh, Mary. Randy said he was able to do the whole thing on a budget of about $80,000. So why didn't we do it? We shot this episode in January. And then remember last week when we talked about how the delivery was supposed to air two different weeks on March 4th and then March 11th, but then both of them got moved. Yeah. So then this episode ended up needing to air before St. Patrick's Day, like way before the parade could have happened. Exactly. And I guess that when Greg got into the editing room, he decided that we didn't really need the footage, that it was working without it. And so the whole thing got cut. Oh man. Randy said that despite all of their efforts that Mary and the city of Scranton were somewhat disappointed, but overall he thinks
哦，天哪，玛丽。兰迪说他能够以大约8万美元的预算完成整件事。那我们为什么不做呢？我们在1月拍摄了这一集。然后还记得上周我们谈到交付本应在3月4日和3月11日这两个不同的周播出，但后来两周都被改了。是的。所以这一集最终需要在圣帕特里克节之前播出，就像在游行可能发生之前很久。没错。我猜当格雷格进入剪辑室时，他决定我们其实不需要这些镜头，没有它们也能行。于是整段都被剪掉了。哦，天哪。兰迪说，尽管他们做出了种种努力，但玛丽和斯克兰顿市还是有些失望，但总体而言，他认为
they were also relieved that they didn't have to change the date of the parade. Well, there's that. When you said that, I was like, oh no, no, no, people would hate us. They'd be like, why aren't we having our parade when we have our parade? Yeah. Wow. That's an amazing story. I had no idea all of that was going on behind the scenes. It's very similar to how Randy tried to get that horse to go over the falls, and then it got pulled at the last minute. Oh my gosh. Randy's job and a lot of work that never comes to fruition. I'm noticing. He has to plan for everything, but not everything gets done. And then somehow he finds a way to get us a new kitchen in the writer's room. The man is amazing. Fast fact number three, while the cast did not get to go to Scranton
他们也松了一口气，因为他们不必更改游行日期。好吧，也有这回事。当你那么说的时候，我想，哦，不，不，不，人们会恨我们的。他们会说，为什么我们不在我们举行游行的时候举行游行？是的。哇。这是一个了不起的故事。我不知道幕后发生了这么多事。这非常类似于兰迪试图让那匹马越过瀑布，然后最后一刻被取消了。哦，天哪。兰迪的工作以及大量从未成果的工作。我注意到了。他必须为一切做好准备，但并非所有事情都能完成。然后不知何故，他想方设法为我们在编剧室弄了一个新厨房。这人太棒了。快讯三，虽然演员们没有去斯克兰顿
for the St. Patrick's Day parade, there is someone from our cast who did march in the St. Patrick's Day parade, and it was our very own Kate Flannery. That's right. Pennsylvania native Kate Flannery was in the Scranton St. Patrick's Day parade. I reached out to Kate and I said, Kate, do you have any stories? How did it come about? Can you share? And she sent in this audio clip. Hey, this is Kate Flannery. I want to tell you all about my time in the Scranton St. Patrick's Day parade in 2017. I was in Pennsylvania, actually Philadelphia with my dad, and they asked if I would be in the parade. I was super proud because I'm Irish. My dad owned a bar in Philadelphia, an Irish bar that my grandfather started. He's from Ireland, my grandfather's from Galway.
参加圣帕特里克节游行，但我们剧组确实有人参加了圣帕特里克节游行，那就是我们亲爱的凯特·弗兰纳里。没错。宾夕法尼亚州本地人凯特·弗兰纳里参加了斯克兰顿圣帕特里克节游行。我联系了凯特，我说，凯特，你有什么故事吗？这是怎么发生的？能分享一下吗？她发来了这段音频片段。嘿，我是凯特·弗兰纳里。我想告诉你们所有关于我2017年参加斯克兰顿圣帕特里克节游行的经历。我在宾夕法尼亚州，实际上是在费城和我爸爸在一起，他们问我是否愿意参加游行。我超级骄傲，因为我是爱尔兰人。我爸爸在费城开了一家酒吧，是我祖父创办的爱尔兰酒吧。他是爱尔兰人，我祖父来自戈尔韦。
So St. Patrick's Day has always been a big deal. And I love that they made Meredith have the same joy for St. Patrick's Day that I do. Just one day, one day. Anyway, I get downstairs from my dad's and there is a limousine waiting for me to take me to Scranton. It is all tricked out with lights and domestic champagne. And I'm like, whew, I am going to Scranton in style. I get there, I am put into a horse drawn carriage at the beginning of the parade, which is so awesome. Of course, I was wearing green. At one point, they took me to the cultural center. So I got to sing Danny Boy with this Irish band for real. And they put me back into the parade and I was with the football team and I got to march. I marched for good part. And then I got to the reviewing
所以圣帕特里克节一直是一件大事。我很高兴他们让梅雷迪思对圣帕特里克节有着和我一样的快乐。就一天，就一天。不管怎样，我从我爸爸楼下来，有一辆加长轿车在等我，带我去斯克兰顿。车里装满了灯光和国产香槟。我想，呼，我要时髦地去斯克兰顿了。我到了那里，在游行开始时被安排坐进一辆马车里，这太棒了。当然，我穿着绿色。有一段时间，他们带我去了文化中心。所以我真的和这个爱尔兰乐队一起唱了《丹尼男孩》。然后他们把我放回游行队伍中，我和橄榄球队在一起，我得以游行。我游行了很大一部分。然后我来到了阅兵台
stand with the mayor of Scranton and I got a plaque. I got a vest with a harp on it. That is part of the Lackawanna County tradition of Irish folks from Scranton. And it was amazing. The only bummer was that when I had to go to the bathroom, they made me cut the ladies room line at Cooper's. There were like 30 women in line. They wanted me dead. They wanted to kill me. They were drinking all day and trying to hold it. It was not good. I don't know why we just couldn't find some random office from the newspaper. Anyway, it was a great day. I love Scranton. Woohoo. And I'm proud to be Irish. So there. What an amazing experience she had. I mean, she has a plaque from being in the parade and a special desk. That story though of where she had to cut the line to the bathroom,
和斯克兰顿市长在一起，我得到了一块牌匾。我得到了一件带有竖琴图案的背心。那是拉克awanna县斯克兰顿爱尔兰人传统的一部分。这太棒了。唯一美中不足的是，当我想去洗手间时，他们让我插队去库珀的女士洗手间。排队的大概有30个女人。她们恨不得杀了我。她们想杀了我。她们喝了一整天酒，一直在憋着。这可真不好。我不知道为什么我们找不到报社的某个随机办公室。不管怎样，这是美好的一天。我爱斯克兰顿。呜呼。我很骄傲自己是爱尔兰人。就是这样。她有了一次多么奇妙的经历。我的意思是，她有一块参加游行的牌匾和一个特别的办公桌。但关于她不得不插队去洗手间的故事，
I'm sure they had her like on a schedule, right? Of course. So they were like, let her through. And the ladies who'd been drinking at Cooper's were like, screw you, lady. Well, that's all I got, lady. Should we take a break? And then we'll talk about how very, very green this office is. Where does this budget come from? Where do they store all the decorations? Who turned the water green? I know. We'll be back. We are back. The office is looking very festive, but Kelly and Ryan are arguing. And you know what? Meredith is not having it. No, not today. Not today. One day. No hassles, no problems, no kids. And then Ryan's like, yeah, where are your kids? And she's like, nope, not today. I texted Kate. I was like, Kate, you are so funny in this and you look so stinking
我确信他们把她的时间安排得很紧，对吧？当然。所以他们会说，让她过去。而在库珀喝酒的女人们则说，去你的，女士。好吧，这就是我所有的了，女士。我们要休息一下吗？然后我们来谈谈这个办公室有多么多么绿。这预算从哪来的？他们把所有的装饰品都存放在哪里？谁把水染绿了？我知道。我们会回来的。我们回来了。办公室看起来非常喜庆，但凯莉和瑞安在吵架。你知道吗？梅雷迪思可不吃这一套。不，今天不。今天不。一天。没有烦恼，没有问题，没有孩子。然后瑞安说，是啊，你的孩子在哪？她说，不，今天不。我给凯特发了短信。我说，凯特，你在这一集里太搞笑了，你看上去太可爱了
cute. We got a fan question from Megan R in South Africa who said, I would really love to hear a breakdown behind the choices made for everyone's St. Patty's Day outfits. I was surprised to see Kevin in a three piece suit. Unsurprised to see Jim in just a subtle green tie, but Meredith's whole outfit was a showstopper. I noticed her outfit right away and her hair like rolled up with the little flower clips. Come on. I went to the script. Her outfit was meticulously scripted. Here is what it said. Reveal Meredith wearing a beautiful dress. Her hair is in a tasteful updo with a green clover intertwined and she wears a tasteful clover wreath. I know she looks like she's in her Sunday best. It's not what you would expect from Meredith on a holiday. No. Did you
我们收到了来自南非梅根·R的粉丝提问，她说，我很想听听每个人圣帕特里克节服装背后选择的解析。我很惊讶看到凯文穿着三件套西装。看到吉姆只系着一条低调的绿色领带并不惊讶，但梅雷迪思的整套衣服惊艳全场。我一眼就注意到了她的衣服，还有她盘起来的头发，上面别着小花夹。拜托。我去看了剧本。她的衣服是精心编排的。上面写着：展现梅雷迪思穿着一件漂亮的裙子。她的头发梳成高雅的盘发，中间缠绕着一朵绿色三叶草，她戴着一个高雅的三叶草花环。我知道她看起来像是穿着最隆重的衣服。这可不是你对节日里梅雷迪思的期望。不。你注意到
notice what Angela Martin is wearing? Pink. No. Not green? No. What? She's wearing like an ivory turtleneck with a beige cardigan and a gray skirt. At one point I have a talking head and I just blend into the wall. You can barely see me. Well, I noticed that you were not wearing green. No. Considering that your character thinks green is hoarse, this day just must be very difficult for you. Oh, I have a whole thing about my character in St. Patrick's Day. I'll share in a bit. We also got a question from Sophia A. in Massachusetts. Who thought of dyeing the water in the water cooler green? It really is such a nice little detail. I'll tell you, Sophia, that was in the script. And there was also a beat where Stanley was going to go to get water
安吉拉·马丁穿的是什么吗？粉色。不。不是绿色？不。什么？她穿着一件象牙白高领毛衣，外搭米色开衫和灰色裙子。有一幕我有独白，我简直融入了墙里。你几乎看不到我。嗯，我注意到你没穿绿色。不。考虑到你的角色认为绿色是粗俗的，这一天对你来说一定非常艰难。哦，我对我的角色在圣帕特里克节有全套的设定。我稍后会分享。我们还收到了来自马萨诸塞州索菲亚·A的提问。谁想出把饮水机里的水染成绿色的？这确实是一个非常好的小细节。我告诉你，索菲亚，那是剧本里写的。还有一个情节是斯坦利去接水，
and then he was going to be annoyed that that was green. Oh, that would have been perfect. I know. That's how they were going to reveal that. But instead it ended up as just a little background moment. The show is going to open with Mega Desk. Dwight has put all three desks together to form this U-shape around him. He's calling it Command Central. He's got surveillance, gaming, and business. That's right. While Jim was off on his paternity leave, Dwight took his desk. Now Jim is trying to figure out what he's going to do. We had a fan question from Cass in San Antonio, Texas, who said, when we see Mega Desk, there is a plant on the left side of Dwight. Is that a beat with a grow light? Because you get a good look at it at one minute, 36 seconds.
然后他会为水是绿色的而感到恼火。哦，那太完美了。我知道。这就是他们揭示这一点的方式。但最终它只变成了一个小背景时刻。节目将以巨型办公桌开场。德怀特把所有三张办公桌拼在一起，在他周围形成这个U形。他称之为指挥中心。他有监控、游戏和商务。没错。当吉姆在休陪产假时，德怀特占了他的办公桌。现在吉姆正在琢磨他该怎么办。我们收到了来自德克萨斯州圣安东尼奥卡斯的粉丝提问，她说，当我们看到巨型办公桌时，德怀特左侧有一株植物。那是带生长灯的情节吗？因为你在1分36秒时能清楚地看到它。
I love the attention to detail. It is a beat. I saw that too. And I loved that there was a grow light. There is another really good shot of it at three minutes and 48 seconds. Lady, I have to say I love that people are sending in time codes now. It makes my day. I thought you would like it. I love it too when I do Insta stories for the podcast because I can go to the time codes that you guys call out. I have to say I also spotted a humidifier and a large, large, like 8 by 10 black and white photo of an old timey woman, maybe his grandmother. There were several framed photos like he brought in stuff from home. Dwight has one of my favorite talking heads where he says, Tweedle D and Tweedle Dumbass have been away on maternity leave and now Tweedle Dumbass is back and we have a problem
我喜欢对细节的关注。这是一个情节。我也看到了。我喜欢有一个生长灯。在3分48秒时，有一个非常好的特写镜头。女士，我必须说我喜欢现在人们发送时间码。这让我的一天都很美好。我想你会喜欢的。我也很喜欢当我为播客做快拍时，因为我可以转到你们说出的时间码。我必须说我还发现了一个加湿器和一个大的，大的，比如8乘10英寸的黑白照片，照片上是一个老派女性，也许是他的祖母。有几个带相框的照片，就像他从家里带东西来一样。德怀特有我最喜欢的独白之一，他说，笨蛋D和笨蛋笨蛋休产假去了，现在笨蛋笨蛋回来了，我们有麻烦了
because he needs more mega desk. It's all he can think about now. I love that Joe Bennett is going to arrive with her dogs. I can't get enough of Joe Bennett. I love Kathy Bates performance. It is so good. I am like crushing on it. Everything between her and Michael in this episode is perfection. I wanted to point out the scene at two minutes, five seconds was actually longer in the shooting draft and Joe goes around and compliments everyone. And I really felt like it set up that Michael storyline about him thinking Joe loves everybody and of course he could go see her in Florida. I thought we should hear it. Candula, I love that sweater. Phyllis, green is definitely your color. Mr. Bratton, you look well rested. Didn't sleep awake?
因为他需要更多巨型办公桌。他现在脑子里想的全是这个。我喜欢乔·贝内特带着她的狗到达。我怎么也看不够乔·贝内特。我喜欢凯西·贝茨的表演。太棒了。我简直迷上它了。她和迈克尔在这集里的对手戏堪称完美。我想指出2分5秒的场景在拍摄剧本中其实更长，乔四处走动并赞美了每个人。我真的觉得这为迈克尔的故事情节做了铺垫，即他认为乔爱所有人，当然他可以去佛罗里达看她。我想我们应该听听看。卡杜拉，我喜欢那件毛衣。菲利斯，绿色绝对适合你。布拉顿先生，你看起来休息得很好。昨晚没睡好吗？
Excuse me Joe, this is that Japanese pistol I was telling you about. Ooh, didn't do it justice boy. That is a fun piece of steel. Oh, she is. I'm going to be dreaming about her from now on. You and me both. I mean, she compliments everyone. Michael just thinks she's pals. They're all pals. It's his dream come true really to have a boss who's a pal. Michael's going to go into the conference room and give Joe a farewell gift. You know, this is her last day in Scranton. Yeah. And then she's heading back to Tallahassee. The gift bag at two minutes and 41 seconds was designed by our graphics designer, Henry Sane. And guess what's inside? A lump of coal. Yes,
打扰一下，乔，这就是我一直跟你说的那个日本手枪。哦，没体现出它的精妙啊，孩子。那真是一件有趣的钢铁。哦，她真是。从现在起我做梦都会梦到她。你我皆如此。我的意思是，她称赞每个人。迈克尔只是觉得他们是好朋友。他们都是好朋友。有一个平易近人的老板，这真的是他梦想成真。迈克尔要走进会议室给乔送一份告别礼物。你知道，这是她在斯克兰顿的最后一天。是的。然后她就要回塔拉哈西了。2分41秒时看到的礼品袋是由我们的图形设计师亨利·塞恩设计的。你猜里面有什么？一小块煤。是的，
from the Anthracite Heritage Museum. You guys, we've shared about the museum before. Or once again, our amazing writers adding a little piece of real Scranton detail to an episode. Joe is a little bit befuddled with this gift, but she's so gracious. And she even tells Michael, you know what? You've got a place to stay if you're ever in Tallahassee. Oh, Joe, Joe, Joe, you cannot say this to Michael. His reaction. Steve's performance and him reacting to this invitation. I have to say, when I was working on that movie with Michael Douglas, solitary man, where I played his daughter, we were working a few days together. We started talking about travel. He asked me if I'd ever been to Spain. I said, oh, no, I've not really ever had a chance to visit
来自无烟煤遗产博物馆。伙计们，我们以前分享过这个博物馆。或者说，我们了不起的作家们再次在剧集中加入了一小块真实的斯克兰顿细节。乔对这份礼物有点糊涂，但她非常亲切。她甚至告诉迈克尔，你知道吗？如果你在塔拉哈西，你有个地方可以住。哦，乔，乔，乔，你不能对迈克尔说这话。他的反应。史蒂夫的表演以及他对此邀请的反应。我必须说，当我当年和迈克尔·道格拉斯合作那部电影《孤独的人》时，我在里面扮演他的女儿，我们一起工作了几天。我们开始谈论旅行。他问我有没有去过西班牙。我说，哦，不，我真的从来没有机会去访问
Spain. He said, you know what? You got to come out. You stay at our house. Open invitation anytime you want. You and your husband, Lee, because he had met Lee. He said, you come out. You stay at our place. And I thought, I don't know what to say now. Is this that thing where someone is just saying that? And I said, oh my gosh, thank you so much. Jenna, wait, wait. Two days later, he said it again. He said, I'm serious. You got to come stay at our place. Just any time. And I'm like, how do I take him up on that? I never did it. I didn't know how to be like, hey, Michael Douglas, remember when you said I can come? Do you talk to Catherine? Yeah, when are you guys going to be there in July? Because we could go or August.
西班牙。他说，你知道吗？你一定要来。你住在我们家。随时欢迎，只要你想来。你和你丈夫李，因为他见过李。他说，你们来吧。住在我们这儿。我想，我现在不知道该说什么了。这是那种别人只是客套一下的事情吗？我说，哦，天哪，非常感谢。詹娜，等等，等等。两天后，他又说了一遍。他说，我是认真的。你一定要来我们家住。随时都可以。我想，我怎么能接受这个邀请呢？我从来没去过。我不知道该怎么说，嘿，迈克尔·道格拉斯，还记得你说过我可以去吗？你跟凯瑟琳聊过吗？是的，你们打算什么时候去？七月吗？因为我们可以去或者八月。
Jenna, I wish I had saved the message because you called me. Oh my God. You called me like after work ended that day. And I had the message for so long. I wish I still had it. And you're like, Ant, the craziest thing happened today. I'm pretty sure Michael Douglas just invited me to his house in Spain. Like he has a house in Spain. And I mean, I've been looking at airfare. I told Lee, maybe we should do this, right? We should do it. Like you were Michael Scott in the moment. You're like, let's get a ticket. Let's get a ticket. Let's plan the drip. I was too shy to follow up, but he offered twice within days apart. The first time I was like, oh, well, that's a polite thing to say. But when you follow it up, then was I rude for not going to stay there?
詹娜，我真希望我把那条信息存下来了。因为你给我打电话了。哦，天哪。那天工作结束后不久你就给我打电话了。我保留那个信息好久了。我真希望我还留着。你说，安特，今天发生了最疯狂的事。我敢肯定迈克尔·道格拉斯刚刚邀请我去他在西班牙的家。就像他在西班牙有一栋房子。我的意思是，我一直在看机票。我告诉李，也许我们应该这样做，对吧？我们应该去。就像当时你就是迈克尔·斯科特。你说，我们买张票吧。买张票吧。计划这次旅行。我太害羞了，没法跟进，但他几天内连续两次发出邀请。第一次我想，哦，好吧，这是一种礼貌的说法。但当你再次提起时，我不去那里住是不是很不礼貌？
I didn't. It was such a kind gesture. Oh my gosh. What do you do? Can we go? Oh, Michael. Can we go? Well, we have a scene between Andy and Aaron that is really cute. Andy walks up to front reception and says, Aaron go bra. And Aaron says Andy go bra and says, nice kilt. Jenna, I had to look up the origin of Aaron go bra. Oh, the word Aaron is of Gaelic origins. It's an Irish word for Ireland. The second part of the phrase go bra, which I'm probably saying wrong. So I apologize. I'm probably not quite saying it correctly. But it means to the end of time. So the phrase sort of means Ireland forever. Oh, there you go. And let's talk about this kilt for a second that Andy's wearing. Well, we need to talk about it because we got a fan mail
我没有。这是一个非常友善的举动。哦，天哪。你该怎么办？我们能去吗？哦，迈克尔。我们能去吗？好吧，我们有安迪和亚伦之间非常可爱的一场戏。安迪走到前台接待处说，亚伦加油。亚伦说安迪加油，并说，不错的苏格兰短裙。詹娜，我不得不查一下“亚伦加油”的起源。哦，词语“亚伦”源于盖尔语。它是爱尔兰语中“爱尔兰”的意思。这个短语的第二部分“加油”，我可能说错了。所以我道歉。我可能说得不太对。但它的意思是“直到时间的尽头”。所以这个短语大致意思是“爱尔兰永存”。哦，原来如此。我们来谈谈安迪身上穿的这件苏格兰短裙。好吧，我们需要谈谈它，因为我们收到了
flurry about it. Did we really? Yes, because he says it's his sister's old field hockey skirt to which a gazillion people said Andy has a sister. Oh, yeah. That's true. She's never mentioned again. We only meet Josh Groban as his little brother. What is going on? Where's the sister? Well, I want to say field hockey is near and dear to my heart. At my high school in St. Louis, Narrocks Hall, I played field hockey not on the team just in gym class, but we have an amazing field hockey team. So I reached out to my friend Liz Millican who still works there. And I asked her for some fun Narrocks Hall field hockey stats. You're going to have to tell me what field hockey is because I don't know what it is. Oh, field hockey. Okay. Well, first of all, you wear kind of a
大量的粉丝邮件。真的吗？是的，因为他说这是他姐姐的旧曲棍球裙，对此无数人说安迪还有一个姐姐。哦，是的。真的。再也没有提及她。我们只见过乔什·格罗班作为他的弟弟。这到底是怎么回事？姐姐在哪？好吧，我想说曲棍球在我心中有着特殊的地位。在圣路易斯的纳罗克斯霍尔高中，我打过曲棍球，不是在校队，只是在体育课上，但我们有一支非常棒的曲棍球团队。所以我联系了我的朋友莉兹·米利根，她还在那里工作。我向她询问了一些有趣的纳罗克斯霍尔曲棍球数据。你得告诉我曲棍球是什么，因为我不知道那是什么。哦，曲棍球。好吧，首先，你穿的是一种
skirt. Okay. And then a top that is just like a regular like sports jersey kind of thing. And you have a wooden sort of hockey stick mallet, but it has a little curve on the end. So not like lacrosse. This is different. It is not lacrosse. Okay. So field hockey, you have a ball. Okay. And you are hitting it down the field. On the grass. Yes. With the wooden stick. With the wooden mallet. And the mallet, it's not, the end of the stick is not as long as a hockey stick. It's more it looks like a little bit of closer to a candy cane. Almost. Okay. Okay. Like, yeah. It doesn't go in a full U. Right. But that is field hockey. And you have a goal at the end. Yes. And you pass it to your players. Yes. Got it. And do both men and women play it? Mostly just women. Got it.
裙子。好吧。然后是一件上衣，就像普通的运动球衣一样。你有一根木制的曲棍球棒锤，但末端有一个小弯曲。所以不像长曲棍球。这不一样。这不是长曲棍球。好吧。所以曲棍球，你有一个球。好吧。你在球场上击打它。在草地上。是的。用木棍。用木槌。木槌，它不是，球棒的末端不像曲棍球棒那么长。它看起来更接近手杖。差不多。好吧。好吧。就像，是的。它不会形成一个完整的U形。对。但这就是曲棍球。你终点有一个球门。是的。你把它传给你的队友。是的。明白了。男女都玩吗？主要是女性。明白了。
It's a woman's sport. Okay. I'm full up to speed. And you played this. I played this in gym class. Liz spoke with the Nareks Hall Athletic Director Nancy Millward and head coach Jody Patterson. They compiled some amazing field hockey stats. For example, Angela, the reason you may not know about field hockey is that it is typically an East Coast sport and then also played in California. In Missouri, there are only 30 high school field hockey teams and only three club teams. This year, Nareks Hall ended their season with a 9-12-1 record. Liz told me that a major highlight of the season was that they won two overtime games against Marquette and Ladoo. This year's team also hosted its first pink out game, which raised close to $400 for breast cancer. I just want to say
这是一项女性运动。好吧。我完全明白了。你玩过这个。我在体育课上玩过这个。莉兹与纳罗克斯霍尔体育总监南希·米尔沃德和主教练乔迪·帕特森进行了交谈。他们整理了一些惊人的曲棍球数据。例如，安吉拉，你可能不知道曲棍球的原因是它通常是一项东海岸运动，也在加利福尼亚州开展。在密苏里州，只有30支高中曲棍球队和3支俱乐部球队。今年，纳罗克斯霍尔以9胜12负1平的战绩结束了赛季。莉兹告诉我，本赛季的一个重大亮点是他们在加时赛中击败了马凯特和拉杜。今年球队还举办了首场粉红之夜比赛，为乳腺癌筹集了近400美元。我只想说
go markers. That was what we were. The Nareks Hall markers. Like a Sharpie marker? We were the hall markers. And so like a hallmark, that was our team were hall markers, but we would call ourselves markers. What's a hall marker? I mean, I guess it's just like a hallmark of history. Just hall markers? I don't, I mean, you're asking good questions. Well, go markers. Thank you. Way to get some butt in field hockey. Thank you. Our big rival is Ursulin and they are the liners because they line the halls. They don't have anything to do with halls. Okay. We're the hall markers. But we would always say that we were gonna X them out those liners. We're gonna X out the liners. This is amazing. This is amazing. This is a glimpse into my high school. I love it. I love it. I would
去标志队。那就是我们以前的名字。纳罗克斯霍尔标志队。就像马克笔吗？我们是霍尔标志队。就像金字招牌，那是我们的团队，我们是霍尔标志队，但我们会称自己为标志。什么是霍尔标志？我的意思是，我想这就像历史的标志。只是霍尔标志？我不知道，我的意思是，你问得很好。好吧，去标志队。谢谢。在曲棍球比赛中表现真棒。谢谢。我们的死对头是乌尔苏林，他们是“排队队”，因为他们在走廊排队。他们和走廊没有任何关系。好吧。我们是霍尔标志队。但我们总是说我们要把那些排队队划掉。我们要把排队队划掉。这太棒了。这太棒了。这是对我的高中的一瞥。我喜欢它。我喜欢它。我
have played field hockey. I love stuff like that. Well, thank you, Liz, so much. That was so fun. I thought immediately of Nareks when I heard that. Andy is going to have a talking head that tonight is their first date. And according to how I met your mother, it's got to be perfect because this is the story you're going to tell your kids. Background catch. Did you notice his talking head was in the annex? Oh, I did not. Not in the conference room. All talking heads in this episode happen outside of the conference room because Joe Bennett and her dogs are in the conference room. Yes. Very soon, Jim is going to have a talking head over by the elevator by Vance for Friduration. I totally noticed. After this Andy talking head, Jenna, there would have been
会打曲棍球的。我喜欢这样的东西。好吧，谢谢莉兹，非常感谢。太有趣了。听到这个我立刻想到了纳罗克斯。安迪将有一段独白，今晚是他们的第一次约会。根据《老爸老妈浪漫史》的说法，这一切必须完美，因为这是你要讲给孩子们听的故事。背景捕捉。你注意到他的独白是在附楼里吗？哦，我没有。不是在会议室。这一集中的所有独白都发生在会议室外面，因为乔·贝内特和她的狗在会议室里。是的。很快，吉姆将在万斯制冷公司旁的电梯旁有一段独白。我完全注意到了。在这段安迪的独白之后，詹娜，本该有
a scene between Oscar and Michael. It was in the shooting draft. It's in the deleted scenes. And we learn Michael's seat preference on an airplane. Is it the middle seat? You got to hear it. You're going to Tallahassee? I am. Joe invited me to stay at her house. So I am booking early to make sure that I can get the middle seat to twice as many people to talk to. I knew it. He wants the middle seat. Yeah. Because he wants to chitty chat with the people on both sides of him. Oh my gosh. He thinks he has to book early for that. I bet he's the guy that's so happy when someone's like, Hey, I'll trade you my middle for your aisle seat. He's probably like, Yeah. Well, the scene would have continued. And Oscar is really going to try to
奥斯卡和迈克尔之间的一场戏。它在拍摄剧本中。它在删减片段中。我们知道了迈克尔在飞机上的座位偏好。是中间座位吗？你得听听看。你要去塔拉哈西吗？是的。乔邀请我住她家。所以我正在提前预订，确保我能买到中间座位，可以和两边的人聊两倍的话题。我就知道。他想要中间座位。是的。因为他想和两边的人喋喋不休。哦，天哪。他以为他必须为此提前预订。我敢打赌他是那种当有人说，嘿，我拿我的中间座位换你的过道座位时，会超级开心的人。他可能会说，嗯。好吧，这场戏本会继续。奥斯卡真的会试着
give Michael some advice. Here it is. I didn't know you guys were that close. You know, we just sort of hit it off. And she actually, she told me that I am funnier than a chimp in a bingo parlor. She loved my tie. You know, Michael, Joe has a way of talking that's really friendly. I know she's the best. Right. But maybe she doesn't always mean those nice things, she says. How can you go through life like that? He's so trying to help him. I know. Well, now Jim is talking to Pam on the phone. Pam's telling him little stories of baby Cece. She sent him a picture of baby Cece all dressed up for the holiday. Okay. That photo on Jim's computer at four minutes and 14 seconds was Charlie Grandi's new baby,
给迈克尔一些建议。给你。我不知道你们关系那么好。你知道，我们只是挺聊得来的。而且她其实，她告诉我，我比宾果游戏厅里的黑猩猩还搞笑。她很喜欢我的领带。你知道，迈克尔，乔说话的方式确实很友好。我知道她是最好的。对吧？但也许她并不总是意味着她说那些好听的话。你怎么能这样过日子呢？他太努力在帮他了。我知道。好吧，现在吉姆在和帕姆打电话。帕姆在给他讲关于小西西的小故事。她发给他一张小西西盛装打扮过节的照片。好吧。4分14秒时吉姆电脑上的那张照片是查理·格兰迪的新生婴儿，
our writer. But Randy sent me the original photo because our graphics designer, Henry Sane, actually photoshopped the little green outfit onto the baby. It was not wearing that originally. But you might also notice in this scene at four minutes, 35 seconds, you can see a photo of baby Cece on Jim's desk. And that was also Charlie Grandi's baby. So on Pam's desk, baby Cece is your sister's child, Cece, your niece. Yes. But on Jim's desk, baby Cece is Charlie's baby. Yes. Two different babies. Soon we are going to cast a set of twins, these two girls, to play Cece, and they are going to then grow up with us and we'll be putting their pictures on our desk. Right. A Jim Dwight storyline is going to start here where Dwight is going to make Jim feel
我们的编剧。但兰迪把原图发给了我，因为我们的图形设计师亨利·塞恩实际上把小绿衣服P到了婴儿身上。它原本没有穿那个。但你可能也会注意到在这个场景中，在4分35秒时，你可以看到吉姆桌上有一张小西西的照片。那也是查理·格兰迪的孩子。所以在帕姆的桌上，小西西是你姐姐的孩子，西西，你的侄女。是的。但在吉姆的桌上，小西西是查理的孩子。是的。两个不同的婴儿。很快我们将挑选一对双胞胎，这两个女孩来扮演西西，然后她们将和我们一起长大，我们会把她们的照片放在我们的桌上。对。吉姆和德怀特的故事情节将从这里开始，德怀特将让吉姆感到
badly about being at work and missing all of these wonderful moments at home with his baby. Okay. I loved this couplet of dialogue. There is a line that Rain had that would have made me laugh if I was doing the scene with him. I wouldn't have been able to get through it. It's when Dwight says that Cece is going to think the refrigerator is her father and Jim says, is that what happened to you? And then Dwight goes, I'll tell you what happened to me. It's like that line. The like sudden like turn of intensity. I'll tell you what happened to me. And then he's like, I didn't see my father for the first two years of my life. He mistook his mom for his dad and his wet nurse for his mom. What was Dwight's childhood? I don't know. We have a really good fan catch from the
因为在工作而错过与宝宝在家里的所有这些美好时刻而感到糟糕。好吧。我喜欢这几句对话。雷恩有一句台词，如果我和他一起拍这场戏，一定会让我笑出来。我肯定没法演完。就是德怀特说西西会认为冰箱是她父亲，而吉姆说，你就是这么过来的吗？然后德怀特说，我来告诉你我是怎么过来的。就像那句台词。那种突然的强度转变。我来告诉你我是怎么过来的。然后他说，我生命的前两年没见过我父亲。他把我妈错认成他爸，把他奶妈错认成他妈。德怀特的童年到底经历了什么？我不知道。我们有一个来自场景的非常棒的粉丝捕捉，
scene, Angela. Page B in Knoxville, Tennessee says at around five minutes, you can see Daryl working in Jim's old office behind Dwight, even though the town hall meeting hasn't happened yet. Was that a continuity slip? Oh, good catch. Page, I'm so impressed. I went to the shooting draft. In the shooting draft, the group scene, the town hall scene was first. Yes. This was going to happen after. Nice catch. But in editing, they swapped them. That was a really good catch. We also got a fan question from Cameron D in Richmond, Virginia. Jenna, what did you do during Pam's maternity leave? Did you get a good amount of time off for this episode and next? I'll tell you what I did, Cameron. I flew home and I spent the week with my sister
安吉拉。田纳西州诺克斯维尔的佩吉·B说，在大约五分钟时，你可以看到达里尔在德怀特身后的吉姆旧办公室里工作，尽管市政厅会议还没开。这是一个连贯性失误吗？哦，好捕捉。佩吉，我太佩服你了。我查了拍摄剧本。在拍摄剧本中，集体场景，市政厅场景在前面。是的。这本该在后面发生。捕捉得真好。但在剪辑中，他们把它们对调了。那真的是一个很好的捕捉。我们还收到了来自弗吉尼亚州里士满卡梅伦·D的提问。詹娜，帕姆休产假期间你做了什么？你为这一集和下一集获得了充足的休假时间吗？我来告诉你我做了什么，卡梅伦。我飞回家，和我姐姐度过了一个星期
and her new baby, my niece, Cece. You got to be a hands-on aunt for a whole week. I did. So I was kind of doing what Pam was doing. I was caring for a newborn. I was on night duty. For that week, my sister could sleep through the night. That's like the best gift you can give a new mom is like a few hours to shower or nap, get some extra sleep. I absolutely loved it. I slept on their couch and Cece slept in a little bassinet next to me and I would kind of doze on and off when she dozed and I would hold her and I would just look so forward to those nights with her when I got her all to myself. Because of course, when my sister was awake, she was like doting on her. She just wanted all of her. So I was like, go to bed, go to bed, go to sleep.
And then I got to just have that little pumpkin all to myself. It was the best. I loved it. That's what I was doing. That is so sweet. Jenna, there is a scene coming up that I have been sent probably 10,000 times in the last two years. Who knew? Who the heck knew? Erin is sneezing at her desk and Angela's like, are you sick? And Erin's like, no, no, no. I just have some indigestion and Angela's like in your nose. Angela's not having it. She goes to her desk and she puts on her very own embroidered mask with her name on it. She's not getting sick. Don't you so wish you had that now? Oh man. I wish I had it. I've been asked that so many times. Well, listen, Erin says she's a little bit sick, but she's trying to push through because she just
does not want to miss her date with Andy. It's so sweet. We got a fan question from Catherine D in Portland, Oregon. Was Ellie Kemper actually sick in this episode or is she faking her congested voice? She is faking you guys. I mean, it's some great sick performance work. It's some great fakey cold work right there. Really good. I was perplexed by what Erin shared in her talking head. She said she usually recovers when she's sick in just a few hours except for the time she was in a hospital from ages three to six. We are learning so many random things about people's backstory in this episode. We really are. Well, now it is time for Jo's Town Hall. She gathers everyone in the bullpen and she says, I want to hear your ideas. She's been hearing ideas from executives,
but she wants to hear from everyone. She says, I mean, did you guys know that liquid paper? That wasn't invented by some fancy engineer. No, that was created by a lowly typist. Well, Kevin chimes in right away. He says, well, I have an idea for a suntan lotion soap. And Jo says, it doesn't have to be an invention, Kevin. Jenna, there were so many alts for that line. What? I went to the suntan lotion soap. I went to the candy bag alts for Kevin's suntan lotion soap. Oh, I'm dying. I literally can't wait. I mean, look how many. Oh my gosh. I can't wait. Okay. Here we go. I can just see right now the writers up in the writer's room pitching like crazy and cracking up over what our Kevin's invention. Okay.
Here are the alts. A hook that you put all your keys on so you don't lose them. Face hat. I don't know exactly what it's for. A device that turns any sink into a urinal. Charcoal filtered underwear. Remote controlled sack adjuster. Orgasm detector. Babe magnet. The never ending French fry. An app that invents apps. What about an invention that makes inventions? Because then you just make that in your home free. I have an invention, pants with a built-in chair. So you always have a place to sit. I got the idea from a time when I got stuck in a chair and just went with it. Wait. That's Michael's invention. I know. I want to see that scene where Michael gets really angry where he's like, that's my invention. They talk about it at company picnic.
I know. Okay. Next one. They have 3D glasses, but do they have ID glasses? I feel like that's probably something that is about to roll out perhaps. Dog biscuits for people. A game that lets you be a swan. Huh. A bicycle powered by licking a lollipop. An app that lists all your condiments. What would you need that app for? I don't know, but there would be some controversy over what a condiment is. Yes. Those were all of Kevin's suntan lotion soap alts. I felt like some of those sounded like Michael Scott inventions. Yeah. But the one that sounded most Kevin to me was never ending French fry. Yes. Also, maybe the remote controlled sack adjuster. Does that mean something adjusts
your balls remotely? Yeah. So you don't have to lean down and touch them. Right. Should you be in public? Yeah. You hit your little remote button and it shifts your balls around. It does it for you. Well, there you go. Well, I got very interested in Joe's comment about the inventor of liquid paper. Did you deep dive? Yes, I did, Angela. And this story is amazing. Liquid paper was invented by Beth Nesmith Graham. In 1954, she was a divorced single mom supporting herself and her son as a secretary working at a bank in Texas. She made about $300 a month. Here's the thing though. She was a really bad typist. And every time she had to correct her mistakes, you either had to kind of like erase it and then it would smudge or you just have to start all over
again. Well, she was also a painter and she thought to herself, you know, when painters make a mistake, they don't erase it or they don't start over. They just paint over it. So she was like, what if I took some of my white tempura paint to work and I painted over my mistakes and I let it dry and then I typed over it. Guess what? It freaking worked. But she was like, I need to make a better formula than just this straight paint. So in her kitchen at home with her blender, she created liquid paper. She put it in little nail polish bottles. Brilliant. And for five years, she and her co-workers at the bank used it. They called it mistake out. Well, then she got the idea. I should do something with this. Yes, you should make this a business. So she hired some teenagers for a dollar an hour to
package it up in her garage and they started shipping it out and sending it to places. She applied for a patent. It caught on. She renamed it liquid paper and they started opening up factories in Dallas, Toronto and Brussels. At its peak, they were making 25 million bottles of liquid paper every year. With her wealth, she established two foundations, one that gave grants and financial support to promote women in the arts and the other which supported women in business. But at one point, while her liquid paper business is booming, she decided to get married again. But guess what this guy did? Please don't tell me he took her money or sold her patent. Please don't tell me. He tried to push her out of her own company and take it over for himself. What a SOB. That's right. He
even tried to change the formula of liquid paper ever so slightly so that he could patent it himself. So that he wouldn't have to pay her royalties on it. Right. Well, guess what? She prevailed. She sold the company in 1979 for $47.5 million. She gave millions of dollars to charity. Sadly, she died six months later from a stroke after selling her company. And incidentally, her son is Michael Nesmith, the guitarist for the monkeys. The rock band, the monkeys. It's his mom. Oh my gosh. Right? That is a fascinating story. I loved that story. Me too. It's just a person solving a problem in their everyday life, you know? That's like my friend. Oh, the cupcake lady. Yes. My friend, Jennifer Gunn, she was a stay-at-home mom. She's
constantly making cupcakes for her kids to take to school. And she was annoyed that they were getting all messed up. She's like, I can't keep putting them in like a shirt box. What am I transporting them with? Right. So she came up with the cupcake courier and she patented it. And she sold it out of her garage for years. And then finally, she sold the design and it's in like Target and all these places. Yeah, you get it everywhere. Bed, bath and beyond. Amazing. When she told me, I was like, how has no one thought of this before? It was this amazing like stackable cupcake transportation device. Josh has one. I know. I brought it on Rachel Ray. I was so excited about it. I was like, give me one. I'm giving one to Rachel Ray when I go on her talk show.
Cupcake courier, liquid paper. Mm-hmm. Mm-hmm. Women solving everyday problems. Yeah. During this town hall meeting, I have to point out how great they build this irritation that Joe has towards Michael. Well, he keeps like doing all these like sidebars. Like he does when anyone else ever is running a meeting. But one person is going to shine in this meeting and it's Daryl. He has an idea about shipment because printers and papers ship differently. Mm-hmm. And he shows this to Joe and she's like, I like this. You should have an office up here. Mm-hmm. And then her dynamic with Gabe is so great. It's so good. Gabe was like, I actually put, you know what, I'm going to pack up my stuff. No problem. Exactly. And this is the moment Michael reveals that he
bought tickets to come to Tallahassee. July 4th weekend. July 4th weekend, but not only that, there's multiple. He booked multiple. Just in case July 4th didn't work out. And Joe's like, no, no, no, you didn't do that. I'm often not home. It's getting so awkward. Michael isn't catching the hint. And finally she's like, enough. Jenna, I remember when we filmed that. You do? You could have heard a pin drop. We were all terrified. She was so powerful in that moment. Like, her acting is so good. It literally shut up the whole room. I love her. And Michael has this line where he says, all right, everybody, just try to put a brave face on. It looks like he's about to cry. Darrell is moving on up to his new office. He's singing. The Jingle from
the Jeffersons. Yes, it was written by Janet Dubois. Randy negotiated just the sync rights to the song, which meant that Craig could sing them acapella, but could have no musical accompaniment. And we could not play the actual song. And it cost us $17,000 for him to sing as he's moving into his new office. Michael is confused. He's upset. He goes in to see Joe. I love when he's like, I'll knock once for yes and twice for no. And she said, how many knocks to get you to do some work? I know. It's so good. Well, lady, I think we should take a break. I do too, because when we come back, the cats in the cradle. Mm hmm. Jim is feeling guilty. Dwight's plan is working. It's working. This is the song that Dwight
is playing while Jim is on a sales call. Yeah. I can't listen to that song. It makes me too sad. I'm so sorry. I just had Sam play it. I can't listen to the whole thing. It bums me out too much. Cats in the Cradle is a 1974 folk rock song by Harry Chapin. I did not know this. The song began as a poem written by his wife, Sandy, inspired by her ex-husband's awkward relationship with his father. Chapin said the song is also about his own relationship with his son, Josh. Basically, I think you guys know what the song is about. But the reason Dwight's playing it is because it's about a man who becomes a father, but he's just too busy to spend time with his son. And his son's always asking him, spend time with me. And the dad's like, we'll find a good time
later. Yeah. But then in the final verse, the son is all grown up and the dad finally wants to spend time with him, but now the son is too busy. And he realizes his son is grown up to be just like him, just too busy for relationship and intimacy. This song makes me sad. And so does the book, The Giving Tree. Always makes me sad. Oh, right. Randy told me that we had to pay for both the sync and the master rights to this song because we both hear the song and then Dwight and Andy sing it. And the total cost for this was $46,000. Well, Jim is going to have a talking head, like you said, outside of Vance refrigeration. And he's going to say, he's not surprised that Dwight is using his baby to steal his desk. But what he is surprised by is that it's working.
This next scene, Erin is going to bring Joe a fax, but she's so clearly sick. Joe's reaction to Erin walking in the room sick. She's like, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, get out. It made me laugh really hard. Lady, am I seriously am I Joe Bennett? I think you might be. That is 100% how I react to a sick person walking into a room. I'm like, oh, wait, not today. I am not getting sick today because of you. You need to go home. I was like that before the pandemic. I know. And now you're really leaning into it. I really am like sniffle. Goodbye. Don't think so. Well, Andy is super bummed out because Joe sends Erin home. And now what are they going to do about their date? Well, Andy has an idea. He's going to go into Joe and he's going to have a bunch of coughing and a bunch of
sticky Joe's going to send him home. Everyone should have started hacking and coughing. They all would have gotten to go to the bar. You're so right. Angela, have you ever pretended to be sick to get out of something? Oh my gosh, you're putting me on the spot. I'm sure I have. You know what? One of the things that just comes to mind, which is so lame, Jenna, but I'm really bad at lying. I'm really bad. And my dad was the same way like a police officer might pull him over for speeding and he'd be like, yep, I was, you're correct. You know what I mean? Yeah. One time I was working at one 800 dentist, you know, I was in my twenties and I had this six AM shift and I overslept and my manager called me and he was so nice. I answered the phone pretty groggy. I was like, hello.
And he said, oh, Angela, are you not feeling well? I said, no, I'm fine. And he said, you had such a chance to get out of it. He said, if you're not feeling well, I can write you up at sick. It's fine. I was like, no, no, no, I'm just tired. He was like, okay, well, can you wake up then and come to work? I said, yeah, yeah, I'll be there. And I told my roommates that and they were like, he literally gave you an out twice. I know. And I was like, no, no. Well, I have a crazy story about pretending to be sick and it involves Molly Shannon speaking of Molly Shannon who's come up twice now on this podcast. What happened? All right. So when I first came to LA, I was working as a typist for the Television Critics
Association. All the stars of all of the new TV shows gather. We've gone to them for the office. And you do a panel and you talk to the Television Critics Association about your new show, about what you're doing. And then in the evenings, they would have these cocktail parties where the cast of these shows would mingle with the press and give quotes. Right. Well, when I first moved here, I was a typist. And what I did was I would attend these panels and I would make notes and then I would get an audio tape and I would go into a little hotel room that was all decked out with computers. And there was a whole group of us shoved in this little hotel room with computers and I would have to transcribe them. And you would have to
transcribe them by the end of the day. And then we would give these transcriptions to all the members of the Critics Association. Wow. So the first time we ever did this press, you knew exactly how it worked. I did. Oh, my God. And I actually told that story on the stage when I was up on the stage and I sent a big basket of cookies to all the typists who I knew were typing everything we were saying. That's so great. So one of the things about this job that was super cool was that if we got our work done on time, we got to go to the parties. Oh, at the end of the day. Yes. And just be like a fly on the wall and looky-loo at all the celebs. So this one night, I heard that the cast of Saturday Night Live was going to be at the party
and I wanted to go so badly. But their party was early. It was the five o'clock party. We never got done by five o'clock. But I was like, I have to go to that party. I have to. So like two days before I started pretending like I was a little bit sick and then on the day of the party. You heard the slow play. I was. I was like, oh my God, I'm just like not getting better. I'm not getting better. But I was also being paid by the hour. So, you know, I had to, that was the thing. Like I had to gradually get sicker because I needed to work until four o'clock. You know, I needed some money. Yeah. So the thing was, was like it was very clear to me that we weren't going to make it to this party. We were not going to get our work
and I wanted to go so badly. But their party was early. It was the five o'clock party. We never got done by five o'clock. But I was like, I have to go to that party. I have to. So like two days before I started pretending like I was a little bit sick and then on the day of the party. You heard the slow play. I was. I was like, oh my god, I'm just like not getting better. I'm not getting better. But I was also being paid by the hour. So, you know, I had to, that was the thing. Like I had to gradually get sicker because I needed to work until four o'clock. You know, I needed some money. Yeah. So the thing was, was like it was very clear to me that we weren't going to make it to this party. We were not going to get our work
done. Right? So I said to my boss, I think I got to go. I'm so sorry. I'm not going to make it to the end of the day. And my boss was like, of course, just go, go, get good rest. We'll see you tomorrow. I'm like, thank you so much. So I left at four o'clock. I went to my car where I had a bag with makeup and a cocktail dress. Holy crap, you love. Yeah. And I put it on and then I realized I couldn't get back in because all I had was my work badge. Well, that's when I noticed the red carpet. Did you walk the red carpet? Sort of. What? So back then there like wasn't a lot of security. No. After the limos would drop celebrities at the carpet, I noticed they didn't look for any credentials. If you got dropped off on a limo, you just got to walk in. Hold up. Were you like
hiding in the bushes waiting for a limo to pull up and then you would just scooch in behind the people? No, that's a good idea, though. That's what mom detectives would do because you know they love hiding in a good bush. They love a bush. Oh, Lord. So I saw the line of limos after they would drop people off. They would just go line up and wait for people to be done like for hours. They just wait till the end of the night. So I went up and I just tapped tapped on a window and I was like, hey, would you be willing to drop me off? Drop me off at the carpet? I cannot believe this story. You knocked on the window to a perfect stranger and said, hey, will you make a loop through the cul-de-sac and give me a little ride to the front door? Yeah. I'm trying to faking
my way in. Yeah. And he was like, sure, why not? Oh, my Lord. He was like, no problem. So he dropped me off at the red carpet. I did not walk the front of the carpet. I did not walk the part where they take your picture. I walked the back part of it. You know where the publicists walk? Yeah, yeah. Okay. I walked in. I went right into the SNL party. It was amazing. I couldn't believe it. I spotted Molly Shannon from across the way and I was like, I have to say something to this woman. I mean, she's everything to me. So I went up. She was talking with a group of press and when they kind of walked away, I just said, Molly Shannon, I just got here to LA. I haven't even been here a year yet and I just want to say you're such an inspiration to me and I love you so much.
And she looked at me, Angela. She put her hands on my shoulders and she said, don't give up. Don't give up. Whatever you do, you do not give up. It took me 10 years to land on Saturday night live. 10 long years. But once I did, my whole life changed. So you just don't give up. Okay? Do you know what that means to a young artist? Yeah. New to town to hear that? Well, I went home that day and I told my mom this encounter and for years, for years, my mom would say to me, Jenna, don't you forget what Molly Shannon said to you. Don't you forget, honey. That's going to make me cry. I'm getting emotional. Lady, your mom quotes Molly Shannon to me. Listen to this. So it was eight years until I landed on the office. 10 years later, my movie, Walk Hard came out
out. And Molly Shannon was at the premiere because Tim Meadows was in the movie, Chris Parnell was in the movie and she had come to support. And I walked across the party and I said, Molly, I'm Jenna Fisher. She said, well, I know who you are. And I said, well, I have a story for you. And I told her that story. And then a photographer came over and took a picture of us. It was exactly 10 years later. We were reunited again at a party. Isn't that insane? That's amazing. Insane. So this woman is a hero of mine. Let me say, taking you back to that original party, the SNL party, as soon as I had my inspirational moment with Molly Shannon. Yes. I am just like on cloud nine. I'm a little in my head. I turn around and I bump into a man and I spill my drink all over him. That man was my
boss. Were you fired? I was fired. He looked at me and he said, looks like you're feeling better. And I said, uh-huh. And there was a pause and I said, I'm guessing I shouldn't come in tomorrow. And he said, you guessed right. But it was worth it. That's my story about faking sick. That is such a great story. And what happened? That is such a great story. But let me tell you, when I tell you like Molly Shannon's book is like you getting to have that moment with Molly Shannon. She gives it to everyone with her book. She is a force. She is a force. I've worked with her and she was the best part of my day every day. I'm sorry for that long tangent. Well, Jenna, I know you share the story in your book and it's so good.
I do. In my book, The Actor's Life. Because now you have two books. I have two books. Yes. Yes. Your book, The Actor's Life, a survival guide. And you share so many of your encounters along the way. Man, that story is amazing. I didn't know that your mom quoted it back to you. For years. That is so sweet. For years. Molly kept me going for years. Wow. Well, thanks for going on that trip down memory lane with me. I loved every second. Now we are in Daryl's new office. And Michael just cannot figure out how Daryl got on Joe's good side.
And I love when Daryl says I presented her with a good idea. You were there. Yeah. Michael, you were there when it happened. I did some work. She liked my work. Yeah. There you go. Everyone's getting restless. They're ready to go. They have been ready to leave since they got to work. Michael tells Joe he's going to scooch on home and she's like, well, do you feel like you put in a good day's work? Can you put your name to this day? Say you did a good job. Michael walks out of the conference room as everyone's leaving. He's like, nope, nope, nope, nope. Well, I want to point out in the conference room at 12 minutes
and 38 seconds, you can see rain in the windows and you are going to continue to see rain out the windows now because I'll tell you why later. Oh, I also have a fan catch from Ruby N in Australia who says when Michael and the office are all trying to leave and Michael comes out from talking with Joe and says they have to stay, you can totally see the reflection of someone's solitaire game in the window when Daryl is sitting down. I saw it. This is a really good catch. It goes by fast, but at 13 minutes and six seconds, you can see a reflection of Creed's solitaire game on the office window. I'd also like to point out that Meredith has a solitaire game on her computer. Kevin is bent out of shape. He has a talking head where he says just because
Joe doesn't have a life doesn't mean they don't have a life. Oscar has a life. He thinks Ryan has a life. There were some alt accounting scenes that happened here. They're in the candy bag. Really? Yes. Thanks again to Rob Burnett for sharing these with us. Here's one that really cracked me up. You know, so everyone's leaving the office. They think they're done for the day, right? This is the scene in accounting after Michael's like, no, no, no, no, no. You have to stay. Oscar says, Angela, I already shut down my computer. Let me check my email on yours. Angela says, no, just turn your computer back on. Oscar says, it takes too long and it makes that loud noise. Angela says, use Kevin's. Oscar says, we disconnected his internet.
Why didn't you reveal Kevin has returned from the bathroom to overhear this? What? You told me the internet didn't reach my desk. Oh, they give him fakie work and he doesn't have internet. Oh, I thought that was a fun deleted scene. That reminds me of the thing you do with kids. Like if you don't want them to have dessert at the restaurant, you just tell them they ran out. Oh, you know what? They ran out of dessert. Yeah. Guess everybody wanted it. Michael's going to call Todd Packer. Oh my gosh, Dave Kekner, guest star in this episode at 13 minutes 21 seconds. What do we have, Jenna? I don't know, what? Behind Michael while he's on the phone. Fakie rain. Fakie rain, y'all.
We got a fan question from Chad T and Montreal, who's really wondering why was there a film crew with Todd Packer at the pub when Michael calls him? It felt a little regular TV to Chad. Chad sort of saying like, why were you prepared to shoot the other side of this phone call? You know, Chad, I thought about this and here's what I decided. I think that they sent a crew ahead at around five o'clock anticipating that the group would be there and the group isn't there yet. That's my explanation. Chad, here's what I'm going to say. You're not wrong. Sometimes we bent the fourth wall here to make the story happen. I have a quick background catch in addition to the Fakie rain. I just want to point out how many wonderful St. Patrick's
State decorations are all throughout the office, including an Irish flag on Michael's desk. Oh, little detail, little detail. I've got a location alert for the old bar. Oh, you want to hear it? I do. It was called Tony's Bar and Grill. Our locations manager, Kyle Alexander, rented it out for three days. It was shut down. We had it all to ourselves. All those people inside are background performers that we hired. The first day they went in was set dressing and lighting. Then we had our one shoot day. Then on the third day, we moved all our stuff out in time for them to open that evening. Thank you, Tony's Bar and Grill. Andy is going to show up at Erin's house with some Gatorade and she opens the door. She's in her jammy jams. I thought that was so cute. Andy, I'm in my jammy jam.
He's in his work, he works. She invites him in out of the rain. Out of the rain. Location alert. This was a real residence in downtown LA. It was right by the bar location. So, we shot the scenes at the bar during the day and then they relocated to this apartment in the evening. Randy said it was actually raining that night. Is that why we had to put fake urine behind Michael? I don't think so. I think that they wrote that it would be raining because they knew it was going to be raining. No. Oh. Because they wanted this moment of Andy at the door in the rain. You know what just came to me? What? This episode is literally don't rain on my parade. What do you mean? It's the St. Patrick's Day. There's a parade. They don't get to go celebrate.
Joe Bennett is raining on their parade and it's raining in real life. Oh, wow. Maybe that's the metaphor. Don't rain on my parade. Well, Randy said that just in case they had a special effects team ready to make fake urine, but they didn't have to. We also rented this apartment for three days. They did the same thing. A day to decorate it, a day to shoot, and then a day to put it back the way the other people had it. Andy and Erin are having a good time. They're snuggling under a blanket. When this guy comes in the room, it's her foster brother. He takes Andy's spot. All of a sudden, he's snuggling with Erin. He's smelling her feet. He's hand on her upper thigh. What is happening? I know. And Andy is like, so like, do you have a parent in common? They're like, no.
No. He's like, how does foster brother work? We're just roommates. We were just in the same house together. He's like, cool, cool. Guest star alert read, Erin's foster brother was played by Sean Davis. He graduated from Juilliard's acting program. He's done a bunch of TV and theater. He is excellent, beyond excellent in the scene. Big shout out to him. We did get a fan question from Susanna H in Orlando, Florida. Why would Erin's foster brother call her Erin? Wasn't her name Kelly growing up? Didn't she only begin to go by Erin at work after Charles Minor got sick of having two Kellys? You guys with all the catches in this episode. I'm so impressed. Right? So Susanna said maybe Erin went home and said to her foster brother,
you have to call me by my middle name now because there's a new Kelly at my job. She'd like us to please discuss. I mean, I definitely could see the character of Erin telling him, you know what? I want to go by Erin now, like fresh new start, new job. Yeah, I can see it. I actually, I like that pitch that that's why. And her foster brother read is in love with her. So he said, sure. Exactly. But I think the truth lies somewhere in nobody thought of that. Yep, is what really happened. Back at the office, Meredith, Creed, Oscar and Kevin are like, we're done. We're walking out. Let's do it. Let's just walk out. Let's just go. So they're set to go. But then Joe comes out of the conference room and then they all just like blow their nose and they bail. They bail. They're
现在你得叫我的中间名了，因为我工作的地方来了一个新凯利。她希望我们能讨论一下。我的意思是，我绝对能看出艾琳这个角色会对他说，你知道吗？我现在想叫艾琳，就像一个崭新的开始，新的工作。是的，我能理解。实际上，我很喜欢这个构想，原因就在于此。而她的寄宿兄弟里德爱上了她，所以他说，当然。完全正确。但我觉得真相介于“没有人想到这一点”之间。是的，这才是真正发生的。回到办公室里，梅雷迪思、克里德、奥斯卡和凯文都在说，我们受够了。我们要走人了。我们走吧。直接走人吧。我们走吧。所以他们准备出发了。但接着乔从会议室里走了出来，然后他们所有人就像是擤了擤鼻涕，然后他们就溜了。他们溜了。他们
scared of her. I'd like to shout out a beat sighting at 14 minutes, 20 seconds. Oh, do you have a beat sighting? The beat with the grow light is now up on the file cabinet. Somebody moved the beat. The beat has been moved. It's still there. Dwight shares with Jim that he has a meeting. He's got to get to wink, wink a meeting. No, Dwight's meeting is real. It is. Yeah. There is no way that Dwight has a meeting at Shani Oganigan's at 7 30. He actually does. He says I have an actual meeting. I think he's just saying that to leave. No, he actually does. He packs his briefcase. He's being earnest. Well, listen, I looked up Shani Oganigan's and there is no Shani Oganigan's in Scranton. There is one in Maryland. I googled it's the three hour drive. We don't even sell
怕她。我想提一下在14分20秒时发现的一个甜菜。哦，你发现甜菜了吗？那个带着植物生长灯的甜菜现在在文件柜上了。有人移动了甜菜。甜菜被移动了。它还在那里。德怀特告诉吉姆他有个会议。他得去开会——眨眼，眨眼——一个会议。不，德怀特的会议是真的。是真的。是的。德怀特绝对不可能在7点30分在肖尼·奥加尼根餐厅有个会议。他真的有。他说我真的有个会议。我觉得他只是为了离开才这么说的。不，他真的有。他收拾了公文包。他是认真的。听着，我查过肖尼·奥加尼根餐厅了，斯克兰顿根本没有肖尼·奥加尼根餐厅。马里兰州有一家。我谷歌了一下，那是三个小时的车程。我们甚至不在那
paper there or printers. Dwight earnestly had a meeting. It's what makes the whole joke work that Jim didn't. I thought Jim stole Dwight's idea to get out of work. Well, I believe that Dwight is earnest and Jim sees an opportunity. Well, I see a poll in our future on Office Ladies Pod Instagram. I think Dwight really had a meeting and one of the things I could not get through in the scene I had to like pause it is Reign's hair. What? What was Reign doing in his real life at this time? His hair is way longer than Dwight's hair normally is and they used a little flat iron but they clearly had more hair to flat iron and it's laying on top of his forehead like these long wispy bangs. I was cracking up. Oh my gosh, I did not notice this. Wait, I took a picture.
里卖纸或打印机。德怀特是认真地去开会的。这正是整个笑话成立的原因，而吉姆却没有。我以为吉姆是偷了德怀特的点子才得以脱身工作的。嗯，我相信德怀特是认真的，而吉姆看到一个机会。好吧，我预料我们的未来在 Office Ladies Pod 的 Instagram 上会有一个投票。我觉得德怀特是真的有个会议，而且在那个场景中我有一点怎么也看不过去，我不得不按下暂停键，那就是雷恩的头发。什么？雷恩当时在现实生活中在干什么？他的头发比德怀特平时的头发长得多，他们用了一把小直板夹，但他们显然有更多的头发需要用直板夹去夹直，它们就那样搭在他的额头上，就像长长的、细碎的刘我当时笑裂了。哦天哪，我竟然没注意到这个。等等，我拍了张照片。
Oh my gosh, please, please look at his poofy long bangs flat ironed hair. Oh, his hair is so long. Yeah, I'm going to put it in stories. So that's what I was looking at in the scene. Jim is going to call Joe Bennett and say he has a meeting. He gets out and now Dwight actually can't go to the one he actually had for those of you that believe he actually had one like me. Coming up is one of my favorite scenes. The cleaning crew arrives with their music blasting and they quickly leave. I have to shout out the cleaner who says sorry, sorry. He was played by Boris Kievsky. He is so, so, so, so good. Do you know how hard it is to like nail an acting moment like that with that amount of just casual reality? I so believed him. I believed the whole world that
哦天哪，求求你，快看看他那蓬松的长刘海，用直板夹拉直的头发。哦，他的头发太长了。是的，我要把它发到快拍里。所以我当时在那个场景里看的就是这个。吉姆要打电话给乔·贝内特，说他有个会议。他出去了，现在德怀特实际上去不了他原本确实有的那个会议了，对于那些像我一样相信他确实有个会议的人来说。接下来是D-我最喜欢的场景之一。清洁人员伴随着震耳欲聋的音乐抵达，然后他们很快就离开了。我必须向那位说“对不起，对不起”的清洁工致敬。他由鲍里斯·基夫斯基饰演。他真的是太、太、太、太棒了。你知道要以那种随意的真实感来完美拿捏这样一个表演时刻有多难吗？我太相信他了。我完全相信整个
was happening with the music and them coming in. He was so good. They all were so good. Amazing. I loved it. I love the detail too that really shows you how long they've been at work because you know if you've been at work when the cleaning crew arrives, you're like, oh crap, I got to go. Randy said that the music they were playing was from the Universal Music Library and it didn't cost us anything. Angela, now you have your very famous talking head. Yes, people quote this at me. Angela Martin says, yes, I'm anxious to get off work, but let me be clear. It's not to celebrate St. Patrick's Day. It's so I can protest St. Patrick's Day. How does one do that? Well, this talking head was actually longer. Oh.
随音乐发生的世界，以及他们走进来。他太棒了。他们所有人都太棒了。太棒了。我太喜欢了。我也很喜欢这个细节，它真正展现了他们工作了多久，因为你知道，如果你在清洁人员到达时还在工作，你就会觉得，哦糟了，我得走了。兰迪说他们放的音乐来自环球音乐库，而且没花我们任何钱。安吉拉，现在你有你非常著名的单人采访了。是的，人们拿这个来对我说。安吉拉·马丁说，是的，我很急着下班，但我要说清楚。这不是为了庆祝圣帕特里克节。这是为了我可以抗议圣帕特里克节。怎么会有人这样做呢？嗯，这个单人采访其实更长。哦。
And in the shooting draft, she went on to say, a group of friends and I meet up with signs and travel from bar to bar. I really look forward to it. I love it. So there were a few candy bag alts for this talking head. I'm going to read you two of them because you know there were like a page and a half. One is so odd. It's about the Steamtown Mall. The other one I'm calling, is this a snarky writer moment? Oh, I can't wait. Sometimes we would read things. We're like, hey. The first one, Angela Martin says, I'm anxious to leave work to get to the Steamtown Mall. It's always empty on St. Patrick's Day. So I finally feel safe to shop. I'm scared of mall trampolings. Okay. And here's the other one. You tell me if there's a little bit of writer's sass.
而在拍摄剧本中，她接着说，我和一群朋友拿着标语碰头，从一个酒吧走到另一个酒吧。我真的很期待。我太喜欢了。所以这个单人采访有几个备选的糖果包。我要读给你们听两个，因为你知道它们大概有一页半长。其中一个太奇怪了。它是关于蒸汽小镇购物中心的。另一个我称之为，这算是一个尖酸刻薄的作家时刻吗？哦，我等不及了。有时我们会读到一些东西。我们会想，嘿。第一个，安吉拉·马丁说，我很急着离开工作去蒸汽小镇购物中心。圣帕特里克节那天它总是空的。所以我终于觉得可以安心购物了。我害怕商场踩踏事件。好吧。这是另一个。你们告诉我这里面是不是带点作家的傲慢。
Yes. Angela Martin says, I'm not afraid of hard work. Do you know what hard work it is to dye my hair platinum blonde each month? I mean, come on. I'm closing in on 40, but my hair looks like Christina Aguilera. Oh, I would say someone in the writer's room had some thoughts on my hair color. I guess so. So now Joe is prepping to go back to Tallahassee. I loved this part. She tells Gabe, ship all her things because she has had it with Homeland Security. But you know what, Angela, that is a sneaky celebrity trick. Do you know about this trick? No. They ship their clothes to their destination so that when they get off the plane, they can just scoot it on out of the airport. Did you know that? Someone told me that. Someone said that they ship their clothes FedEx.
是的。安吉拉·马丁说，我不怕辛苦工作。你知道每个月把头发染成白金 blond 有多辛苦吗？我是说，拜访一下嘛。我快四十岁了，但我的头发看起来像克里斯蒂娜·阿奎莱拉。哦，我会说编剧室里有人对我的发色有想法。我想是的。所以现在乔正准备回塔拉哈西。我很喜欢这部分。她告诉加比，把她所有的东西都运走，因为她已经受够了国土安全部。但你知道吗，安吉拉，那是一个偷偷摸摸的名人把戏。你知道这个把戏吗？不知道。他们把衣服运到目的地，这样当他们下飞机时，就可以直接溜出机场了。你知道吗？有人告诉我那个。有人说他们把衣服用联邦快递寄走。
I could never do it. What if the package got lost and then you got where you're going and you don't have any clothes? Yeah. Then isn't everything wrinkled, but I guess it gets wrinkled in your suitcase too. Yeah. That's a thing though. Joe is doing the sneaky trick. After speaking with Gabe about how late Joe usually works, Michael has decided he's going to take matters into his own hands and he's going to walk in to Joe Bennett and he is going to say that he is pleased with his employees performance today and he's going to send them home for the night. And by the way, he's also canceled his trips to Tallahassee. So you know, he looks forward to their working relationship. The end. And I think for once, Joe respects Michael in a moment because he stood
我绝对做不到。万一包裹丢了，然后你到了目的地却没有任何衣服呢？对啊。那衣服不会全皱了吗，不过我想放在行李箱里也会皱吧。对啊。不过确实有这回事。乔正在玩这个偷偷摸摸的把戏。在跟加比谈过乔平时工作到多晚之后，迈克尔决定要亲自动手，他要走进乔·贝内特的办公室，他要说他对员工今天的表现很满意，并且他要让他们今晚提前下班。顺便说一句，他还取消了去塔拉哈西的行程。所以你看，他很期待他们未来的工作关系。结束。而且我觉得有那么一次，乔在这一刻尊重了迈克尔，因为他挺身
up for his workers. He did. He did. And she says, I look forward to that too. And then the whole gang gets to go out to the bar and they like Michael. It's really this nice moment where, you know, they're happy to be out at a bar with Michael. He saved the night. Andy and Aaron's date, if you can call it a date, has come to an end and it looks like they're about to kiss. But then of course, Reed pops in. Yep. And Aaron gives Andy a very long lingering kiss on the cheek. It's very sweet. Pretty much everyone is having a good night. In the end. In the end. Well, there is a tag, Jenna, where Dwight arrives to find Jim sitting atop a three desk pile that he has dubbed quad desk, right? There was an alt for the scene. Oh. In the shooting draft, it says,
而出了，为了他的员工。他确实做到了。他确实做到了。她说，我也很期待。然后整个帮派就可以去酒吧了，他们喜欢迈克尔。这真的是一个很美好的时刻，你知道的，他们很高兴能和迈克尔一起去酒吧。他拯救了今晚。安迪和艾琳的约会，如果这也能算约会的话，已经结束了，看起来他们就要亲吻了。但当然，里德突然插进来了。是的。然后艾琳给了安迪一个非常漫长而依依不舍的脸颊吻。非常甜蜜。几乎每个人都度过了一个美好的夜晚。到最后。到最后。嗯，还有一个彩蛋，珍娜，德怀特到达后发现吉姆坐在一个由三个办公桌堆叠而成的组合上，他称之为四重办公桌，对吧？这个场景有一个备选方案。哦。
Jim has taken Dwight's mega desk configuration and rearranged it. Three desks stacked on top of each other. Each desk still has all its equipment, computer, phone, etc. There is a step ladder set up as a chair. And Jim is standing on the step ladder working at the top level desk when Dwight enters. Dwight says, what the hell is this? Where's mega desk? Jim says, gone, replaced by something better. Tower desk. Oh, tower desk. And Dwight has this talking head where he's like, well, now I want a tower desk. I'm going to make one at home. Four levels. I have a silo. I can have five levels. Wow. So that was the alternate. But instead, we ended up with quad desk and a teeny, tiny little desk underneath them all for Dwight. Aw. You guys, that was St. Patrick's Day. It was.
在拍摄剧本中，上面写着，吉姆拿走了德怀特的超级办公桌配置并重新进行了排列。三张办公桌叠在彼此上面。每张办公桌依然保留着所有的设备，电脑、电话等等。架设了一个作为椅子的活梯。而吉姆正站在活梯上在最顶层的办公桌工作，这时德怀特进来了。德怀特说，这到底是什么鬼？超级办公桌呢？吉姆说，没了，被更好的东西取代了。塔式办公桌。哦，塔式办公桌。而德怀特有一个单人采访，他说，好吧，现在我也想要一个塔式办公桌。我要在家做一个。四层。我有一个筒仓。我可以做五层。哇。所以那是备选方案。但相反，我们最终得到的是四重办公桌，而在它们所有人下方为德怀特准备了一个微型小办公桌。啊。你们这些家伙，那是圣帕特里克节。确实是。
Thanks for celebrating this episode with us. Thank you to Kate Flannery for sharing with us about being in the Scranton St. Patrick's Day parade. And thank you to Molly Shannon for being a remarkable human being and changing my life, keeping me going, I should say. We hope you guys keep going and keep believing in yourselves and that you have a fantastic rest of the week. Don't give up. Don't give up. We'll see you next time. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton.
感谢大家和我们一起庆祝这一集。感谢凯特·弗兰内里与我们分享参加斯克兰顿圣帕特里克节游行的经历。也感谢莫莉·香农成为一个非凡的人，改变了我的生活，让我坚持下去，我应该这么说。我们希望你们也能坚持下去，保持对自己的信念，并祝你们这一周剩下的时间过得愉快。不要放弃。不要放弃。我们下期见。感谢收听 Office Ladies。Office Ladies 由 Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西制作。我们的节目执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的 Rubber Tree。
For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code OFFICE. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
有关 Office Ladies 的无广告版本，请访问 StitcherPremium.com。如需在 Stitcher Premium 免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码 OFFICE。本集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。